each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you for coming my name is Kevin
Koontz and I'm here to welcome Daniel
Lieberman to the Microsoft Research
visiting speaker series Daniel is here
today to discuss his book the story of
the human body
evolution health and disease the human
body is undergone numerous changes over
millions of years while all this
evolution certainly brings benefits such
as greater longevity it has also helped
create conditions our bodies can't
handle like obesity and type 2 diabetes
Daniel Lieberman is professor of human
evolutionary biology and the Lerner
professor of biological sciences at
Harvard he is well known for his
research on the evolution of the human
head and on running especially barefoot
running his research and discoveries
have been highlighted widely in the
media please join me in giving him a
warm welcome thank you so much it's a
real pleasure to be here now if I stand
here will I be able to is okay okay and
can you okay I guess I'm liked okay so
first of all thank you for inviting me
it's a kind of an honor a pleasure and
kind of I find it a little bit bizarre
to be here at Microsoft a sort of fabled
place I spend a lot of place where a lot
of time working in parts of the world
where computers don't even exist so it's
fun to come to the other extreme in fact
we try to bring computers every summer
to the places we work at in in Africa so
it's fun to experience this amazing
amazing place so I'd like to talk about
a question or actually a pair of
questions that have evolved over the
last 2000 years since I've been teaching
human evolution when I when I first
started teaching human evolution I was
pretty much fascinated with and and
focused on telling the story of the
human body in terms of the family tree
you know who begat whom you know
teaching students about Australopithecus
afarensis and africanus and Homo habilis
and Homo erectus and all that kind of
stuff and the dates and who found them
and over the years I've become more and
more interested not so much in in that
story but it rather the story
of how the body itself has changed and
also why that's relevant and and a large
extent to a large extent that's because
of the questions that my students asked
after all most of them don't become like
me
professors most of them go on to become
doctors or or software engineers or
whatever and they're they're not going
to remember the minut differences
between one species or another species
but they all have bodies and they all
use their bodies and they all care about
how other people's bodies are
functioning and so so my book really is
an attempt to try to answer two
questions which have sort of risen over
the years in my and my teaching and one
is and my research which is why is the
human body the way it is and the second
is why is that relevant today why should
we care about that evolutionary history
I'm going to try to very briefly
summarize some of my thoughts and the
first 150 or so pages of the book
actually tells the the evolutionary
story of the body and obviously there's
no way I can do that in a 35 40 minute
lecture let me just briefly summarize
that there I've see at five major
transformations that really allowed that
really caused our bodies to to diverge
from us simply essentially I sort of
chimpanzee like creature around 6
million years ago after the bodies that
we have today and the first one was the
origins of bipedalism so our very first
ancestors appear to have been bipeds but
but Apes Apes that basically walked on
on two legs and then excuse me another
major shift occurred around 4 million
years ago with the genus
Australopithecus so some of you have
heard of Lucy for example she was a very
famous australopith excuse me and she
was adapted to more open habitats into
eating diets other than just fruit all
day long because chimps for example that
basically all they do eat is eat fruit
90% of their diet is fruit then around
two two-and-a-half maybe even three
million years ago it starts there is a
shift to hunting and gathering right
with the origins of the genus Homo
brains get bigger people start
cooperating they start processing their
food they start running they start
throwing modern bodies more or less
evolved then but that wasn't the end of
evolutionary bodies because the
descendants of Homo erectus got grew
even bigger brains and even larger
bodies and slowed down their rate of
reproduction and and probably became
fatter and all kinds of other
transformations and the final major
shift was
actually just a small one from an
evolutionary perspective it's the
origins of our own species right Homo
sapiens and we're basically very much
like Neanderthals and other archaic
human cousins except we differ primarily
above the neck but of course what
happened above the neck in in humans
especially in our brains and our ability
to communicate through language had
major effects on of course the entire
world and still is today so those are
that's like a five-second you know and
maybe a five-minute intro to everything
that happened in human evolution but now
let's move on because let's just assume
we've read all those chapters you
understand it all and let's think about
the consequences of those shifts and the
important point is that you stand back
from all those five transformations each
of which was an improbable event prompt
many of them driven by climate change if
you stand back what we end up with is a
creature like us that was evolved to be
bipedal slightly fat so typical
chimpanzee or typical ape has about five
or six percent body fat but even lean
human beings so hunter-gatherers or
supermodels have maybe 10 or 15 maybe
even 20% body fat so we're very fat
species compared to most most mammals
were furless we're sweaty
we're big brained were dependent on
tools but of course the other factors
that we're very interested in today is
our diet and activity adaptations right
so we're adapted to eat a diet that's
very high in fiber and low in
carbohydrates but we're also adapted to
crave energy right so we love sugar we
love fat we love starch
we're also adapted to be highly
physically active I'll show you some
data that in a second but we also
adapted to enjoy comfort and to enjoy
rest whenever possible and it's these
transformations of course that are very
important in today's world so humans
didn't stop evolving when we evolved
when our species evolved around 200 250
thousand years ago evolution has been
continuing and it's even going on today
after all natural selection is the
outcome is the emergent property of
heritable variation so variations that
you inherit from your parents and
differential reproductive success that's
related to those variations so
individuals with with variations that
cause them to have fewer offspring or
more offspring then result in change
from one generation to the next in terms
of the percentage of those
jeans and so it's still going on there's
actually evidence for natural selection
going on today like one of the biggest
studies I was talking to somebody here
from Framingham one of the biggest uh DS
going on today is the Framingham study
where people are actually documenting
selection that's occurring right now in
our in our lifetime but so although
natural selection is still going on
anybody with who you know space aliens
came to the earth and were to observe us
for a while what they what they most
notice about us is our culture right our
cultural behaviors and and there's
another form of evolution that's going
on that's also incredibly important it's
cultural evolution right so cultures
essentially what we learn you also
inherit culture from your parents but
you learn it from each other or from the
internet or reading a book or going to a
lecture and cultures change over time
they change very rapidly just think
about the last 5,000 years or so of
changes in texts and script right it's
it's been amazing transformation and a
lot of it going on right here and
Microsoft is is still still still being
transformed in fact you know probably
what makes this such an important
companies its its role in cultural
evolution if you really think about the
what's with the Internet age so it's a
very important force and but if you
stand back from the details of what's
gone on since our species have evolved I
would say there's two really big
transformations that so stand out again
this is very broad brush right the first
of course is the origins of farming the
Agricultural Revolution which actually
happened seven times independently the
first first incidences of Agriculture
about 10,000 years ago in the Middle
East also at the same time in China but
elsewhere in different parts of the
world and of course that transformed the
world in terms of the food that we eat
right we get a lot more food so we have
much larger population sizes but also
people start living in in cities and
towns and and surrounding themselves
with their own waste products and and
interacting with animals and getting
diseases so along with more food and
more people also came a lot more
infectious diseases then the other sort
of huge transformation was the origins
of the Agri conduct really evolution as
well as modern science right those
happened hand-in-hand they were they're
interrelated and through industry we've
been able to generate more food of
course there's been incredible
population explosion and at first as
cities started to swell infectious
disease rates went up even more but then
with the invention of sanitation and
antibiotics and and various other
aspects of modern medicine we've now
become able to combat many of those
infectious diseases that were unleashed
initially by the Agricultural Revolution
and then and then became even more
important during the industrial
revolution so arguably today is the
healthiest era in human history and let
me give you a few bits of information to
try to convince you of just how how good
good it is today so one important fact
is or measure of health is infant
mortality so today in developed
countries such as the United States
infant mortality rates are less than 1%
but that's actually very unusual for
most of the human evolutionary history
we know that during the Paleolithic
infant mortality rates were pretty high
we can measure them in hunter-gatherer
populations we can estimate them from
population size estimates from the
fossil record and when farming evolved
although people had more offspring
because they were able to have them more
rapidly infant mortality rates were
still extremely high about 30 to 40
percent is a reasonable average of
course there's a lot of variation around
these numbers and it's only been very
recently again as I said really since
the invention of penicillin antibiotics
that infant mortality rates have plunged
to the rates we have today adult
mortality has also changed so if you
survive childhood it turns out that many
people think hunter-gatherers live
horrible nasty brutish lives it's not
true if they survive childhood actually
they live to be pretty old they live to
be into their 60s to their 80s and it
was with the origins of farming that
mortality rates started to plunge
precipitously as people then started
dying from all kinds of infectious
diseases and malnutrition and famine and
all those things that that that affect
farmers and it's only again since
invention of modern medicine and
sanitation and various other wonderful
things that again mortality rates have
climbed back up again and actually we're
not too different from our politicans
esters again if you discount in
mortality that occurs during childhood
so the end result of this of course is
growth in world population right so the
world was pretty unpopulated until the
origins of farming then it started
increased very slowly this is billions
here by the way and of course with the
Industrial Revolution there's been an
incredible accelerated increase in
population today the world has more than
seven billion people and I guess the
best estimates are for by the end of the
century you should have more than nine
billion people on the planet so so all
this of course is as a result of lots of
people having lots of babies who survive
but there are other ways of measuring
health
a good one is stature so all of us have
a certain genetic potential to grow to
idea there's many many genes which
influence how tall you're going to be
but not of all so all of us reach that
height because of usually insults to our
growth right so if you have infections
or malnutrition or other problems you
don't actually reach your your your your
your genetic potential so height
actually turns out to be a really useful
measure of overall health and so this is
a graph of height of males in Europe
I've actually taken French male since
the Napoleon and this guy over here and
these are European Paleolithic males and
you can see that during the Ice Age
during the during the Paleolithic people
were about 5 foot 8 inches in Europe
then during farming again health
declined precipitously around the world
people shrank down to about 5 foot 4 and
here's Napoleon and we all know a famous
shrimp and then and then height started
to increase again with the Industrial
Revolution and now actually we've not
only caught up with but we they can
slightly exceed it even in France their
Paleolithic ancestors so the average
Frenchman is now 5 foot 10
Homo erectus varied a lot in height
depending upon where they were so that
Homo erectus is a species that evolved
around 2 million years ago and served
and died out well when extinct in
different parts of the world there are
ancestors in Africa for example Homo
erectus was pretty tall but there are
examples of homo erectus populations in
some parts of the world that really
worth much shorter like for example in
the Caucasus they were quite short so
there's a lot of variation height in the
Paleolithic just as there is today a lot
of that of course driven by selection
but the important point is that although
health is doing really well today by
many markers we could also clearly be
doing a lot better and the way of the
best way the caps encapsulating this is
what's called the epidemiological
transition and some of you may have
heard of this but if you just stand back
from the last few hundred years and look
at what has happened recently we know
that there's been a incredible decline
in in death and illness that comes from
infectious diseases as well as
malnutrition right so our ancestors were
much more likely to die of plague and
smallpox and tuberculosis and infectious
diseases such as that so those those
diseases now most of us don't even worry
about that anymore
right but but what's but what's risen in
concert with that is is non infectious
diseases so today we die from cancer and
from heart disease and osteoporosis and
type 2 diabetes and various autoimmune
disorders these are all on the rise and
there's actually a lot of evidence that
they're on the rise and some of you have
seen these famous graphs I mean this one
is is plastered all over the place it's
very hard to go anywhere without seeing
graphs about the the shift in in obesity
around the world but suffice it to say
that during my lifetime the percentage
of people in the United States who are
obese has more than doubled along with
that has been a rise in a whole series
of other diseases such as type 2
diabetes which is going up in the US and
also going up and it even faster rates
in many developing countries such as
China or India where where diabetes
rates are climbing at at really alarming
rates breast cancer the list goes on of
non-infectious diseases whose incidence
is going up I'm not talking bout death
from these disease I'm talking about the
incidence of these diseases and there's
a whole series of other diseases that
people are getting to like myopia and
cavities and lower back pain and
flat feet and various mental health
issues and acid reflux we don't have a
huge amount of data on some of them like
Alzheimer's from the Paleolithic but
there's a good good bet that most of
these diseases are becoming much more
prevalent today and I'll show you some
of the evidence for that in a second so
is this just the price of progress many
people would think well of course you
know if you're not going to die young
from smallpox or the plague you know
we're actually lucky to be able to live
to be old and die from cancer or heart
disease right this is actually a
trade-off right if you're living longer
and to some extent that's actually true
for example think of cancer cancer is a
disease caused by by mutations right in
mutations accrue with time so as you
live longer you're more likely to
acquire mutations to some extent but it
turns out that if you look at the at the
evidence that's only a partial
explanation because and for and one of
the major reasons for that is that it's
very important not to confuse diseases
that are more common as you age with
diseases that are actually caused by
aging and so and it and the the
hypothesis and from the field of
evolutionary medicine and evolutionary
medicine is the field of essentially
applying evolutionary theory Darwinian
biology to medicine and disease so the
evolutionary medicine hypothesis and you
know this wonderful book by Nessie and
Williams why we get sick it's really
serve students that people encounter
today these non infectious diseases and
actually many infectious diseases as
well are what we call mismatch diseases
it's important term if there's any term
you remember from this lecture I hope
it's mismatch disease and those are
defined as diseases that are more common
or more severe because our bodies are
inadequately or poorly adapted to novel
environmental conditions in which which
they experience right and so I actually
as an experiment try to list all the
mismatched diseases that I think are
common today in our culture and it was a
pretty unpleasant task let me tell you
and I should mention that this is I use
the word hypothesize for a reason
because we lack a lot of good data on
hunter-gatherers so we don't know for
example about you know ulcer rates or or
preeclampsia among hunter-gatherers but
there's a compelling arguments to
believe that many of these diseases are
either more common or sometimes even
a novel because of the environmental
conditions in which we live in and by
the way this is just these are just the
non infectious diseases
how do I put in the infectious diseases
that have arisen since the origins of
Agriculture this would be a really truly
scary and horrible list and I've left
those out okay and you think these
diseases are important the chances are
that most of us in this room are
actually going to die from mismatch
diseases so the number one cause of
death in the United States today is
coronary heart disease kills about a
third of Americans the evidence shows
that coronary heart disease used to be
extremely rare to the point essentially
non-existent among hunter-gatherers
cancers are ancient they you know
dinosaurs have cancer
dogs get cancer etc cancer is certainly
not a novel disease but the evidence
clearly is that cancer rates have been
rising particularly many kinds of cancer
around the world so that's another
mismatch disease and you know cirrhosis
type two diabetes metabolic syndrome
hypertension osteoporosis these are all
common diseases today that are costing
us billions but which are which are
which are mismatched diseases in fact if
you think about the United States today
we're having this big debate about
health care we spend about two and a
half trillion dollars per year in
healthcare the estimates are that about
70 percent of the disease that we treat
the United States is preventable and I
would argue that almost all of those are
mismatched diseases so we are really
confronting an epidemiological
transition that's costing us an enormous
amount not only in terms of it money but
also in terms of misery so I'm the
origin so why we get sick from these
diseases is important but I think an
equally important perspective is what do
we do when we get sick from these
diseases and here is where I think the
importance of cultural evolution comes
in because because how we respond to
these diseases is setting up an
interesting new dynamic so many of you
may know that I'm interested in running
and in barefoot running and in feet and
so I have a bit of a foot fetish so I'm
going to use a foot example to kind of
explain this right so we obviously
evolved to be barefoot until recently
shoes didn't exist anywhere on the
planet
and when shoes were invented they were
very minimal right so our bodies were
adapted to be either barefoot or wearing
very minimal shoes okay so what happens
well we invented all kinds of novel
shoes and looking around the room I see
quite an interesting variety of shoes
here and many of the shoes we invent are
cushioned and they're comfortable or
they're sexy and they have all kinds of
features that we like about them right
but there's also no question that those
chooses cause a variety of problems
including flat feet so I work with
barefoot populations around the world I
can tell you that barefoot people don't
get flat feet it's almost completely
non-existent right and we can make a
very compelling case that flat feet are
caused by shoes which cause your feet to
become weak so you don't develop an arch
or your arch collapses right so that's a
mismatch disease not a very serious one
but nonetheless a mismatch disease so
what do we do well we go see a
podiatrist who gives us an orthotic and
there's nothing wrong with that the
orthotic basically replaces the natural
arch of the foot it's fine you can live
with a flat foot affect probably about a
third of the people in this room have
flat feet and are wearing orthotics
maybe because it's Microsoft maybe it's
bit more than a third I don't know
anyway but the point is sorry that was a
cheap dig the point is though that what
happens is that sets up a vicious circle
right because it because we can get away
with flat seat right we can then
continue to have the shoes that call
their feet to be flat and keep the cycle
going so we don't pass on flat feet to
our children although there was a
genetic base there there's some genetic
proclivity towards flat feet but but
those genes aren't novel genes that have
swept through our you know the United
States and the last few generations
causing an epidemic of flat feet what's
happened is those are ancient genes that
are interacting with modern environments
and then we're basically continuing the
cycle and I think this cycle is so
important so so vital to think about
that I think it deserves a term now I'm
not the first person to come up with
this idea of this vicious cycle but I
but I would propose that we call it this
evolution disk for bad in evolution for
change over time so another example
would be something I work on I work on
heads as well is that if you if you eat
very soft processed food you don't chew
very much chewing is necessary to grow a
proper sized jaw if you don't grow up
proper size jaw your third molars your
wisdom teeth can't go in so they become
impacted so you have to go to an oral
surgeon to have them removed which
enables us to continue to eat food all
day long that doesn't require much
chewing which keeps the cycle going and
my hypothesis is that this vicious
circle this dynamic dis evolution is a
really important cause of the underlying
underlying the epidemiological
transition that we're experiencing and
let me try to try to give you a few bits
of criteria by which to
judge this so characteristics of
mismatch diseases that generate this
kind of feedback loop are first that
they're caused by gene environment
interactions pretty much all diseases
have a genetic basis to some extent to
them right but what's happened what's
changed there's not the genes it's the
environments that have changed okay I
think that's not a pretty
non-controversial statement secondly for
most of these diseases the environmental
causes of them are very hard to perceive
they're incremental make happen step by
step and there's no obvious relationship
between cause and effect like all of you
folks are sitting very comfortably in
these chairs and it probably all of you
are aware of the data that sitting in
chair is ain't good for you right but we
do it nonetheless and sitting in a chair
for an hour is not going to cause you to
die instantly
right but you keep doing it over and
over and over again hour after hour day
after day year after year decade after
decade that the problems caused by
sitting in chairs accrues very slowly
third I don't think anybody's died from
sitting in chairs right most of the
diseases that we get from this mismatch
don't don't affect reproductive success
they don't tend to occur to us until
we've had not only our children often
our grandchildren so we're already quite
old and so they don't really affect how
many offspring you leave and then
survive and have offspring and finally
all of them are based in in causes that
have trade-offs right their benefits to
chairs for example they help you sit at
a computer for example I'm sure people
in this room are very interested in that
right so there's always trade-offs
everything involves trade-offs so let's
look at three different kinds of
examples of this of this of this vicious
circle and I'll first start with
environmental changes that involve too
much of a stimulus and we'll talk about
little of a normal stimulus and then
finally environmental changes that
create two novelist stimulus so let's
start with too much because that's on
everybody's mind today right so one of
my major arguments is that we evolved to
be sort of gas guzzlers of the primate
world we're very energy intensive
species even even hunter-gatherers right
and that actually that transformation
really started around to two and a half
million years ago with the origins of
the genus Homo it's when brain size for
example started really increasing
rapidly and brains are very expensive
tissues if you're sitting here listening
to me you're using about 20% of your
body's resting metabolism just to pay
for you
brain and if you're dozing off you're
still using about 20% of your metabolism
to pay for your brain brains are costly
tissues guzzling vast amounts of energy
all the time so big brains are very
expensive you have to pay for them big
brains are costly but an even more
costly aspect of our biology is our
reproductive strategy so we evolved from
creatures that were sort of ape-like
well they were Apes actually and they
they probably reproduced about every six
years so a chimpanzee for example has
offspring every six years but
hunter-gatherers are able to have
offspring every three years so basically
they can double the rate at which they
pump out babies and not only do we pump
them out faster which takes a lot of
energy right because each baby costs a
lot of energy we also we also grow them
more slowly so here's Prince Prince
William for example at the age of 13 and
you can see that that he's still not
even shaving but if he had been a
chimpanzee he would be an adult ready to
ready to have you know starting to
breathe right and have offspring right
we have extended our our period of the
trajectory of development slowed it down
incredibly by about 50% adding an
enormous amount of cost to the to
raising to raising a child to become
reproductive so we slowed it down made
them more costly with bigger brains and
bigger bodies pump them out faster which
takes a lot of energy this is a very
energy intensive system and how did we
get the energy to have this kind of
biology right and the answer is I
mentioned it before hunting and
gathering now hunting and gathering
didn't occur some all at once like two
million years ago like somebody sort of
invented it like like like the computer
right it involved probably very slowly
but it involves the combination of a
number of important human behaviors
making tools for example which really
takes off around 2 and 1/2 million years
ago food processing hunting which didn't
really start until around then endurance
running one of my passions
begins around then the ability to throw
Spears for example in order hunt starts
around then did we also know there must
have been an important division of labor
and intense cooperation all these things
combined together to create a novel way
of life that enables hunter-gatherers
get more energy than their ancestors
probably were able to do and importantly
the food that provides that energy we're
foods that were high in carbohydrates
hi and fat hunting and gathering things
like tubers or or honey so we're very
dependent and we crave as a species
carbohydrates and fat but and and for
for millions of years our ancestors got
them through hunting and gathering but
the origins of Agriculture transformed
our ability to get these resources right
we started to grow them right we around
around you know the oldest farming is
from the Middle East and from China and
it's only been around for about 600
generations that's the number of
generations of dogs that have come and
gone since the time of Christ right not
a lot of generations and we've
transformed what we eat pretty much
everything we ate today I had a nice
lunch in the cafeteria here at Microsoft
and all the food I ate was domesticated
in fact public FISC for a few sources
and of course in the last few
generations we even created
industrialization of food right we grow
we grow meat like like we like we build
cars right we're able to turn corn into
sugar and that's of course further
transformed our ability to get
carbohydrates and fat in just a few
generations so important examples of
this are for example how much sugar and
fiber we eat right so hunter-gatherers
don't get a lot of sugar the most of the
wild fruits that you get out in say
Africa are about as sweet as a carrot I
can tell you this from a personal
experience they're they're not that
sweet right and they come loaded with a
lot of fiber and the only cerhaygurl ood
that hunter-gatherers can get is honey
they don't get as much of it as they
would like
so estimates are that pale ethic
hunter-gatherers probably got about 4 to
8 pounds of sugar a year and we all know
that today Americans well we grow it by
the drugs we turn our corn into sugar
and the average American gets about a
hundred pounds of sugar a year
importantly that sugar we get today is
not is it's been had it's from the
sources of sugar have had its fiber
removed
so a typical hunter-gatherer it's about
80 pounds of fiber a year that's normal
typical American eats about 12 pounds of
fiber a year right and we think that's
normal today but it isn't and the reason
it's a problem is because of food
processing and how that affects the way
we metabolize foods so carbohydrates are
broken down into sugars or we just have
the sugar raw and and it enters our body
you
and it gets converted either into
glucose or fructose and glucose go
straight into your bloodstream and that
causes an insulin response and foods
that are high in glucose but also low in
fiber go very rapidly into the
bloodstream causing rapid spike in blood
sugar levels which causes then a rapid
spike in insulin levels which then
caused a crash in blood sugar levels
which leads to more eating and also
leads to various problems fructose has
to go to your liver your liver can't
handle that much sugar that fast because
so in the absence of fiber because fiber
slows the rate at which again the sugar
gets into the bloodstream so so foods
that are very high in sugar and low in
carbohydrate but it's basically
presented kind of double whammy to our
bodies and they create what's called
metabolic syndrome an increase in belly
fat and cholesterol and blood pressure
and blood sugar rates and any of you
want to read the the there's a wonderful
recent book about this called fat chance
by Robert Lustig which explains a lot of
the biology so this leads to a variety
of diseases one of them being type-2
diabetes right so it's a it's a gene
that's caused by interactions between
our genes in our environment there are
genes which predispose some people
towards being more likely to get type
type-2 diabetes than others but it's the
environment that really causes these
diseases to become much more common and
that until the end so for example high
amounts of central adiposity belly fat
essentially is a major risk factor which
leads to insulin resistance which is
when the cells in your body no longer
able to resent insulin which then which
then which into which acts to basically
take blood sugar sugar from out of your
blood and basically into your cells so
what happens is you set this vicious
circle we get high levels of blood sugar
your insulin levels spike because
they're trying to get the blood sugar
out of your body blood sugar by the way
it's very toxic and overly high levels
eventually your pancreas essentially
wears out which means that blood sugar
levels remain high and insulin levels
remain high and eventually the whole
system crashes so what do we do about
type-2 diabetes well we have two major
responses right one is through
medication right there's lots of drugs
out there which help treat that that
system I just showed you earlier but of
course the other thing we prescribe is
is exercise and good old-fashioned
sensible diets and both of these are
important ways to treat type two
diabetics
the important point to remember and it's
not a it's very insightful point is that
medication of course doesn't cure
anybody of diabetes it helps mitigate
the system symptoms it allows people to
live with the disease but exercise and
diet actually can prevent diabetes and
in fact in extreme cases it can cause
the disease to go into remission you can
actually reverse diabetes with serious
exercise and very very good diet and of
course there's lots of other benefits
from exercise so I would argue that
because of this feedback loop when
people don't use exercise and diet as
much as medication to treat diabetes
it's become a disease of dissolution
right where we have a gene-environment
interaction in which yes there are some
genes which predispose some people more
to diabetes than to others but those
genes haven't just suddenly swept
through human populations its
environmental shifts that are causing
diabetes to become more common then the
the causes of diabetes are very
incremental and non-obvious you know
when you have the orange juice for
breakfast you know you don't you don't
feel the diabetes coming on you know
just from drinking that orange juice
right or not going for a run
the disease has little or no effect on
reproduction because most people don't
get the disease until after they've
reproduced often when their grandparents
and of course there's a trade-off
between the costs and benefits of the
environmental shifts that have led to
diabetes in the first place so there are
many other examples of diseases of too
much but let's move on to another
example of diseases of too little right
and it's axiomatic in biology that
almost every system of our body requires
stress to grow properly and by stress I
don't mean like social stress like you
know getting it from people and them not
laughing at your jokes for example
that's very stressful right um what I
mean by stresses is environmental
stimuli that require your body to have
to work harder right and there are many
examples and one example of course is
your muscles muscular system we all know
that for example if you want to grow you
know bigger biceps you have to lift
heavy weights which causes essentially a
muscle damage which then so elicits a
response to the muscle then hypertrophy
then grows right so no strain no gain or
sometimes people say no pain no gain is
a real phenomenon it's necessary to
allow capacity to match demand but also
muscles are very expensive about 40% of
most people's metabolism is used to pay
just for the muscle in your body so if
you're not going to be using it and
you're an environment where energy was
Limited which is what was the case for
most of human evolution it's best to get
rid of it when you don't need it right
so if we don't use our muscles as our
former governor of California
experienced you lose that muscle mass
right that's a natural tendency right
and that's a that prevents over capacity
it's it's evolutions way of a gift of
matching capacity to demand properly
well there's lots of examples of stress
that are important and perhaps none are
more important today to talk about than
physical activity which is well known to
have a variety of effects on many
systems in the body through stress your
cardiovascular system your muscles your
your your digestive system your immune
system physical activities turns out and
the stress it causes is incredibly
important for neural your
neurobiological health as well and
related to Alzheimer's in and depression
and anxiety and even the ability to
learn and remember things but and but
the important point is that the
importance of physical activity in human
health is not a coincidence I would
actually argue it's because of
evolutionary history because part of
hunting and gathering involves being an
athlete our ancestors who are Apes
probably didn't walk very much typical
chimpanzee walks about two to three
kilometres a day and maybe climbs about
100 meters a day on trees in fact if you
go watch chimpanzees they kind of spend
half the day just putting food in their
mouths that's basically all they do and
then they digest it and they fill their
guts again they actually spend 50% of
their day eating again that's also what
used to be normal gorillas actually
spend even less time moving about they
actually traveled about a kilometer a
day but your average hunter-gatherer is
a worldwide average average female
hunter-gatherer travels a nine
kilometres a day the average male
hunter-gatherer clot travels 15 commerce
today so so five to ten miles a day to
put that into perspective
your average hunter-gatherer goes at
least from LA to Washington walking
every year right and they work every day
they do physical activity dancing
walking running climbing digging
throwing there are no bank holidays
there are no weekends there's no
retirement this is this is what life was
like until extremely recently and one
way to measure that is there are many
ways to measure physical activity a very
simple way is called a physical activity
level or a pal physical activity level
is just the
energy you spend every day divided by
the amount of energy that you need to
maintain your body so basically how much
energy you spend if you're in bed
basically doing nothing in a perfectly
climate-controlled room right
so most hunter-gatherers have physical
activity levels there's a lot of
variation I'm simplifying horribly here
right but the average is about 1.9
so that means they spend about as much
energy using their bodies as they spend
maintaining their bodies so it's oh all
right subsistence farmers we're just a
little bit harder working than
hunter-gatherers so they have averaged
about two and again there's a huge
amount of variation around these numbers
but people who live sedentary office
lives like me right have physical
activity levels of about 1.5 to 1.6
that's an enormous reduction that's a
greater than 15 percent reduction right
and there are many examples and one
example that I kind of like is sewing
machines right there
so of course back in the Paleolithic
when people so they sewed by hand right
and then in the with the Industrial
Revolution people invented this you know
singer invented the sewing machine which
had this pedal my grandmother actually
used one of these right as a pedal that
moves the motor and and now of course we
have electric sewing machines and there
is actually a bunch of folks who have
actually measured they put oxygen masks
on people using different kinds of
sewing machines and actually doing just
about everything else you can imagine
and it turns out that a pedal sewing
machine cost you about 98 kilocalories
an hour an electric sewing machine here
used by the mayor of London actually I'm
not sure if he's really sewing but
anyway here's about seventy three
kilocalories that how you think okay 15
calories an hour that's like nothing
right well imagine these folks are
unionized right so only working five
days a week eight hour days 50 weeks a
year that adds up to 52 thousand
calories a year which by the way is
enough energy to run 18 marathons right
and just that's just putting an electric
motor on a sewing machine now add in you
know escalators and elevators and
shopping carts and and and all the other
conveniences in our lives we have
transformed a human work in the last few
generations like we've never transformed
it before and has incredible effects so
just think about it we actually their
estimates are we spend about 300 to 500
calories less per day doing physical
activity than
or ants that are great than our
grandparents that's an amazing
astonishing transformation in human
biology and there are many effects of
that physical inactivity I'm just going
to pick out of the hat one of them that
I'm very interested in it's osteoporosis
so this is a disease that's basically
unknown among hunter-gatherers or
substance subsistence farmers but it's
rising around the world at very alarming
rates in the United States now about 30%
of women over the age of 50 in about 10%
of men over the age of 50 are now
diagnosed with osteoporosis and this is
rising everywhere this is a very
alarming disease and it's because by
forces affecting growth so here's a
here's the guy won the US Open this year
right Rafael Nadal and you can see that
his uh his left arm is much thicker than
his right arm because it's the army uses
to play tennis with he holds the racquet
right now the jeans and his left and
right arm are obviously the same right I
don't think he's a chimera and he's got
a lot more muscle mass in his left arm
and he's also got thicker bones because
the bones actually respond to loading we
know that bones again experienced that
trade-off just like muscles right you
will if you're using your bones a lot
you want them to grow thicker so that
they they can handle the loads and if
you're not using them very much you
actually they'll waste away they grow
thinner and so astronauts for example go
off into space essentially get
osteoporosis because their bones just
waste away in microgravity so this this
relationship between physical activity
and bone growth however comes up against
a very ancient constraint and that
constraint is that we grow our skeletons
when we're young and we lose skeletal
mass as we age that's just the way
mammals are sorry there's nothing we can
do about it so most of us hit hit peak
bone mass between about the ages of 20
and 30 and as we've discussed before
people are more active when they're
young acquire higher peak bone mass they
build better skeletons then we all lose
it as we age and if you're a woman you
lose it in a faster rate once you go
through menopause because of estrogen
estrogen plays a very protective role
for bone health
so individuals who are inactive grow
less peak bone mass and they can also
lose their bone in a faster rate than
people are active and the end result is
that inactive people are much more
likely to fall below the bone mass
threshold that
osteoporosis and so that's why
osteoporosis on the rise so it's another
example of dis evolution right it's a
disease that's caused by an interaction
interaction between genes in our
environment and it's not like genes for
osteoporosis have certainly swept
through our culture or population
it's our environmental changes caused by
electric sewing machines and cars and
shopping carts and all kinds of other
things right every time you use a
shopping cart you don't think oh my gosh
it's contributing to my osteoporosis you
can't even feel its effects on your
bones right but the incremental effects
add up slowly slowly bit by bit over the
years it has no effect on reproduction
because most people don't get the
disease until their grandparents and
obviously there are many benefits to
cards cars and shopping carts and
elevators so there's a trade-off for all
these things right I'm not saying that
we should get rid of cars or shopping
carts but we have to understand that
everything involves costs and benefits
that get traded off finally diseases
caused by things that are tuned you
we're all very aware of the fact that
our environments are filled with with
novel stimuli that we never experienced
when we were in the old days like bungee
jumping cars cigarettes various kinds of
pollutants in our environment you could
add computers for example and there's
there's no question that we're not
always well adapted to those aspects or
environments so here's an example here's
a here's a gentleman who looks like a
perfectly respectable person but we all
like to be like this guy right here he
is he's reading he's sitting in a nice
comfy chair he's wearing shoes well in
actual fact all these things are
basically killers right well I mean I'm
exaggerating a little bit they're not
killers but they all cause health
problems right and I'll just pick as an
example reading right because it's
something that we all care about
profoundly right so reading is obviously
a very recent phenomenon right we we we
you know we started around 3000 BC and
it's only in the 19th century that
Universal literacy really started to
explode right and so now most people
read in least in developed nations right
and it's actually around that time that
people began to notice something was
going on so here's a quote from James
ware who was a physician to the
queensguard and he noticed quote among
the Queen's Guard officers many were
myopic so that these are these are from
the upper classes right while of the
10,000 foot guards who come from
lower classes less than half a dozen
we're myopic we're nearsighted right and
we've now know that this is actually
well documented all around the world
less than 3% of hunter-gatherers and
subsistence farmers have myopia this is
a very very recent phenomenon in our
environment in some countries like in
Asia for example some countries have
about 50% rates of myopia and it's
caused by having an overly long eyeball
right so what happens is that light from
like photons from me hit your eye you
focus them on your retina but if your
eyeball is too long you can't focus them
even more you're your lens and your
cornea can only focus them so much and
so things that are distant are blurry
and there are two interesting mechanisms
that cause myopia and there's a big
debate that's going on but one of them
is close work right when you stare at
something that's up close right if
you're myopic you're always doing that
all the time right
even glasses make everything still up
close you're firing these muscles in
your eyes called the ciliary muscles
they attach these little filaments that
hold your lens up in fact they're those
filaments have a wonderful name they're
called those annuals of Zen I just
happen to love their name it's
irrelevant but the point is that those
muscles are always contracting and that
contraction of course generates force
which actually increases the pressure
and they in that in the main cavity of
the eyeball which causes the eyeball to
stretch and it's thought that that's one
of the factors that causes overly long
eyeballs and that's why people who spend
a lot of time standing their microscopes
are doing close work are likely to have
their their vision worsen however it
also turns out that that doesn't explain
all of myopia so there's these gruesome
experiments that we're done and back in
the old days when they would stitch the
eyes lids of animals shut not to study
myopia but they discovered that these
animals who clearly we're not reading or
doing close work right these eyes we're
not being used at all developed myopia
and they developed overly long eyeballs
and it turns out that there are stimuli
there clearly necessary from vision that
actually regulate eyeball growth and if
you have you lacked appropriate visual
stimuli your eyeball grows too long so
there were some kind of repressive
repressor mechanism going on and and
they're actually a lot of data to
support this hypothesis it turns out
that for example children who spend more
time outdoors regardless how much
reading they do are less likely to
develop myopia so the bottom line is
that myopia is a complex disease it's
nope there's no question it's
caused by gene-environment interactions
there are people whose genes make them
more likely to get the disease but
obviously it's caused by environmental
factors that interact with those genes
every time you read a book or don't go
outside doesn't you know you don't feel
the effects on your eyeball length right
so it's very hard to figure out what
actually even causes myopia obviously it
has little or no effect on reproduction
thank God right and there's no question
that the benefits of reading outweigh
the cost right I mean most of us are not
going to ban books because it causes
myopia right or for that matter
computers or all those other wonderful
inventions we're willing to tolerate
them but nonetheless it's example of dis
evolution so what are our solutions well
one is let's make our kids play outside
more and that's I think a no-brainer and
maybe we can develop ebooks and other
visual stimuli that are more dynamic
that are less likely to to to cause that
problem in the retina so finally in the
last few minutes I just want to end with
some thoughts about how an evolutionary
medicine approach and evolutionary
perspective can help us think about
about the future of the human body
because there's a very famous expression
by the great geneticist theodosius
dobzhansky that nothing in biology makes
sense except in the light of evolution
and in the field of evolution medicine
we would argue that includes medicine so
what's the perspective that we can get
about this epidemiological transition
that can help us think about how we can
decrease the burden of non-infectious
diseases as the burden of infectious
diseases is declining right well if you
stand back from the details I would say
there's four basic options that are
available to us as a species right the
first option is to do nothing let's just
let natural selection solve the problem
right a second and is to invest more in
treatment you know basically send NIH
more money which is kind of difficult
when the government shuts down but
anyway that's another story
we can certainly educate people more so
they better understand how their bodies
work so they can make two informed
choices and finally we can change your
environments and I would argue that of
all of these we should do everything
except that do nothing right that I
don't think is an option for one even if
natural selection could solve these
problems which is very debatable it
would take too long for it to be of any
practical use to any of the people that
we care about it would take hundreds if
not thousands of generations furthermore
there's a lot of reasons why
there's no necessary reason to believe
that natural selection is going to adapt
us to high-fructose diets right because
it only works if there are heritable
variations which actually affect
reproductive success so it's it's a very
iffy statement I could spend hours
talking about two and three and there's
no question we should do that I think we
don't spend enough on on treatment we
don't spend enough on education but from
an evolutionary biological perspective
there's reasons to be skeptical that we
can do so much through either right one
is that a lot of the genes that are
important in the gene environment
interactions that we that were used for
pharma pharmaceuticals for example those
genes tend to be a very small effect and
they're very numerous and they're also
turned out to be very uncommon so the
gene that I may have inherited that make
me more susceptible diabetes would make
are not the genes that for example would
make you more susceptible to diabetes
and even that in those jeans
turns out don't even have a very strong
effect there's no there's not going to
be these are these are diseases that
have multiple complex causes and there's
not going to be a pass door for these
diseases which is why progress in
solving many of these non infectious
disease is going to be very slow and
incremental as it has been and it's
going to remain and slow and incremental
I hope I'm prove drawn for some of these
diseases but but that's your buddy's
best guess education is also very
important but there's many reasons and
many studies which show that education
is only so effective for one even public
service announcements are drowned out by
about 27 to one by advertisements for
for foods that are very unhealthy for
example but even more importantly even
though we may know what's good for us
it's very hard for us to actually make
decisions about that's what's good for
us for example when people are you know
when there's a stairway next to an
escalator do you know what percentage of
people take the stairway as opposed to
the escalator five percent god you guys
are good right yeah it turns out the
worldwide average I think is three
percent and when you put a sign up
saying please take the stairway it
doubles to about six percent and you
know that's just human nature if you
were to put an escalator in the Kalahari
Desert the Bushmen there would do the
same thing it's it's normal because if
you're on the threshold of energy
balance it makes sense not to waste
energy climbing the stairs right because
you can use that energy to reproduce and
to hunt to do something that's going to
bend
fit you the same thing is true over you
if you put a piece of cake in front of
me and a piece of celery of course I'm
going to eat the cake
I'm evolved to prefer the cake it makes
sense there's nothing wrong with that
right
so overcoming those urges those
instincts those primal urges is going to
be very difficult and those of you who
are interested in behavioral economics
you may know like Daniel Kahneman's book
thinking fast thinking slow there's a
lot of research on this on this problem
now and and it there these are very hard
to overcome
so education I think is only going to do
so much which leaves finally the final
shift is changing our environments right
if you think about it as I said before
you know we have all to be bipedal and
fat and fur lists and and tool-using and
but importantly we evolved to eat high
fiber diets that are low in
carbohydrates but to crave sugar starch
and fat we evolved to be very physically
active right but to enjoy taking it easy
when it's possible so the problem is
that we never evolved to make the
choices that we now confront in our
lives right so you know if you were able
to travel back in a time machine to this
homo erectus family you would not hear
that mother or father telling their kid
okay you know a little you know you
don't forget to eat the healthy food
today and don't forget to exercise right
little had no choice but to exercise
and eat healthy food there was nothing
else for her to do right that was called
life and if you didn't do what you died
right but today we have to nag our
children to to make the right choices
because we're surrounded by by by by
labor-saving devices and by by by
calorie rich food especially without
fiber and filled with sugar that make us
sick so we have this mismatch again
between these ancient genes which we're
not gonna be able to change and novel
environments which we can't change
and so that's where I think our big
debate ought to be instead of having the
debate we're having today about about
about health care which is really about
who's going to pay I think we should
also be having a debate about how we can
change our environments and that's
missing from the current debate and
there's really two extremes right one
view is to coerce people right then
trans-fats and you know ban smoking and
then fast food from children's
cafeterias and require coercively
physical education right that's one
that's one approach the other approach
is to respect people's choices but to
kind of help them make the choices that
they would make that are in their own
self best interest
that's nudging right and I and that
would be include things like sugar taxes
and and you know signs encouraging
people to use the stairs and Mayor
Bloomberg's big gulp and actually I
would classify as a nudge
it's interesting how people were so
reacted so vigorously against the big
gulp ban he wasn't banning soda he just
made it if you wanted to get I think it
was a thirty six ounces if you want to
get thirty six hours you have to buy two
16-ounce so does right I mean it wasn't
he wasn't banning soda he was just
making it harder to get those large
quantities anyway the point is that we
have we need to have a more informed
debate about it and I think we're where
that debate really is probably most
obvious is for children because children
really can't make rational decisions on
their own we we long ago agreed that we
have to make decisions on their behalf
right so we nobody debates anymore that
we should require seatbelts for children
or require them to go to school or
require immunizations well maybe there
are a few people who debate
immunizations but they shouldn't right
so so what about physical activity right
my in Massachusetts where I'm from we
just we I can tell you it's a miserable
state in terms of physical activity we
do you know the American College of
Sports Medicine in the Surgeon General
both agree that children need about an
hour of vigorous activity every day to
have a healthy body how many schools
give their kids an hour of physical
activity a day right we view it as a
trade-off so you know they don't have
enough physical activity because they
need time to study for their exams but
of course it's a false trade-off because
physical education actually improves
mental health as well we are doing our
children a terrible unconscionable
disservice by not requiring more
rigorous and vigorous physical physical
activity in schools and we also have
cook bans and coercion right we I mean
who disagrees that children should be
banned from smoking or drinking right so
if that's the case how is junk food any
different maybe we should ban junk food
from schools as well so I hope that 10
years from now we look back on this
debate and think oh yeah the junk food
tax and the physical education laws
those were no brain that he enacted in
the 2000 the second generation decade of
the 2000s so you know those were no
brainers just like we think about
seatbelts and smoking the bottom line
though is that we are not going to get
out of this problem without thinking
about evolution evolution still matters
right it helps explain
why we are the way we are explains why
we get sick and I also think it helps us
evaluate the opportunities available to
us to make the human body better off in
the future and so with that I'd like to
thank you very much and answer any
questions thank you yes in your research
has all has culture played into all
these environmental choices is that a
difference for example between Eastern
culture and what is acceptable what's
not acceptable behavior does that play a
role in choices you have and how can be
worse so that's not actually something I
work on too much so the question is how
much do different cultures stress
behaviors that have outcomes on health
differently and the answer of course is
enormous Lee and and and we see the
differences in in in health outcomes
from one culture to another but of
course one thing is interesting is how
fast cultures are changing around the
planet right as as industrialization
spreads and as fast food spreads and
processed food spreads and and urban
urbanization and mechanization spreads
those cultures are changing really
rapidly much more rapidly than ancient
cultural traditions I mean most cultures
you know what your grandmother taught
you right about what's you know a
healthy lifestyle is pretty much
universal I would argue you know get
enough sleep eat lots of vegetables you
get lots of exercise these are these are
kind of no-brainers around the world
people know this but changes our is our
ability to continue to do these yes I
got confused with the one with genetics
all diseases so you might win my doctor
asked me if my color actually had high
blood pressure that doesn't mean that
even we go further somebody in the gym
didn't have high blood pressure
so what developing the genes during the
Holland Center so so the genes that make
people for example more susceptible to
things like high blood pressure or
diabetes right they're not novel genes
their ancient genes but so so so maybe
your grandfather or your father also had
high blood pressure but if you went back
30 40 generations they didn't have high
blood pressure but they had the same
genes so those genes haven't changed the
environments that caught that that that
that interact with the genes that
trigger the disease have changed and
furthermore the genes that may make you
susceptible to high blood pressure are
not the genes that may make the person
sitting next you susceptible to high
blood pressure because there are lots of
genes and they tend to have all very
small effects and so that makes it very
hard to find a gene that causes high
blood pressure
there is no gene that causes high blood
pressure and they're not common genes
and they're not genes of large effect
yes so you said it life expectancy now
and um the Palaeolithic was more or less
the same but that the disease that we
have now are very different so what was
worse the college of death then if you
if you know it so what caused people to
die in the para that great questions so
so infant mortality of course was high
in the pillow the connect was from
diarrhea and infectious diseases things
like that so what people died from in
the pale with ik was violence and they
died from respiratory diseases and they
probably died from accidents but they
didn't desire from diabetes or heart
disease so so so we you know we've done
pretty well in many respects but but but
not not completely yes able to reduce
those non-infectious diseases like the
diabetes and the part
what would we die off we'd die of old
age I'm just thinking about we all know
people who I mean eventually your body
does you do everybody who's very old
gets hypertension right everybody's very
old does succumb to authentic just slow
cardiovascular problems etc but but we
wouldn't be dying from but also the
other itching that's interesting about
people who die don't die from many of
these mismatch diseases they also have
they tend to die more rapidly it's a
it's a it's it's called the the
compression of morbidity or rather
what's what's happening is what we call
the extension of morbidity so people
today are sick for longer at the end of
their lives and they go to very very
long declines we all know what I'm
talking about right but if you look for
people who are very healthy for example
there's a very famous study by guy named
Jim freezers at Stanford very he's done
a number of studies on this but he's
shown that people who basically exercise
and eat a healthy diet tend to have tend
to become sick later in life
considerably later in life and when they
do get sick they get sick for less long
and then they and they basically die
better deaths if I lack of a better term
so so we're essentially we've extended
morbidity illness
and may made the process of dying much
more much more costly and much more
suffering yes compared to memos or so
about human disease very long life and
so given that a population has extended
so much and essentially you're not
talking about extinction level scenario
right out of it what does having a much
longer life do for us as a species and
people don't live routine 77080 and are
like what how does it count it so what's
the advantages of living longer right
well there are many so one of them is
actually it's a it's a wonderful
hypothesis called the grandmother effect
right so hunter-gatherers remember
hundred gathers are gathering food every
day undergone mother can't get enough
food actually to pay for her energetic
needs on her own right and it but plus
her offspring it's very hard and it's in
a day out there in the Kalahari Desert
or you know somewhere else
for a mother to get enough food done I'd
pay for her own body but for her infant
who's nursing and her children and her
toddlers etc who who are now post
nursing but she still has to feed them
so mothers need help they get help from
father's right but also they get help
from grandparents grandfathers and
grandmothers both provide important
surpluses which help pay for their
offspring and it's again only recently
that we stop the system of life right so
so grandparents in the Paleolithic
played very important roles in in their
own reproductive success and today in a
strange way we kind of inverted that
right because now grandparents no longer
feed their kids right or their
grandchildren I mean my grandmother
brought me cookies and stuff like that
and wasn't always great but but for that
wasn't necessary my parents didn't need
my grandparents to bring cookies from
New York to keep me alive and you can
actually even argue that grandparents
now because of health care costs for the
age that are actually sucking up the
resources that could go to their
grandchildren there's kind of macabre
thought you could even make the
prediction that that there's actually
gonna be selection against against
living long
just because of economic conditions and
the cost of health care I mean I'm not
that's a facetious argument I'm not sure
if that's really true and I hope it's
not but but so really longevity evolved
a long time ago for for the purposes of
improving reproduction again natural
selection really only acts when it
benefits how many offspring you have who
then survive to have offspring yes you
mentioned the effect of reading them on
myopia and no no we must have some
statistic or night I gloss for very long
I know and of course we know about
Gutenberg who have got both cheap so
mortals could reach them without going
bankrupt so he'll tell them when he
tries what happen when printing spread
around you or sure when printing spread
myopia increased but of course at first
it was just among just among the
educated I mean when Gutenberg was
praying his Bibles most people couldn't
read so as I said before the evidence is
that prior to the universal literacy it
was really only the very wealthy be very
educated who got myopia and now it's
everywhere right yes knowledge and
insight what are the things that you've
adopted in your personal life and your
you know maybe family practice to avoid
this problem gosh so uh so how do I
avoid being a hypocrite um well I I mean
I'm you know I'm no saint I'm subject to
the same cravings as everybody else but
I try to run a lot I love running I try
to promote physical activity I try to
force my daughter to be physically
active and you know poor thing and I'm
careful about my diet pretty much like
most people uh or many people you know
look this thing about about diet and
exercise is that you know they're not
they're not magic bullets you know
eating a healthy diet and exercising
does not guarantee long life but not
exercising and eating a poor diet
certainly increases your risk of being
ill and being and having you know
increases your risk of morbidity and and
we're all susceptible to the same
problems and I think you know
trick us to help each other make the
right choices and so uh so I try to use
forms of self coercion like for one the
reasons I like marathons is not because
I love the marathon so much but because
it forces me to exercise right because I
know I'm a I'm a race coming up I forces
me to get there and a horrible you know
I come from Boston you know it's
horrible weather most of the year right
and you know I'd rather not get out of
bed and do a long run but I have a race
coming up and I promised some friends
I'm going to meet them and I have to go
out there and do the run and I usually
enjoy it afterwards but I don't love it
at first no it's it's it's it's self
coercion I think I'm not going to answer
that on camera i back in the back yeah
well we're we're perpetrating I mean
there's there's there's there's a dog
obesity epidemic canal going on
absolutely you know yes so I've seen the
latest training shoes these running
shoes that look like a foot you know
there's minimalist cushion so then what
how does a body who's been wearing other
types of shoes for 40
years what's the impact of now switching
to something great question so the
question is what's the what's what
happens if you've been wearing
conventional shoes for most of your life
and all of a sudden you switch to
minimal shoes the answer is you get
injured probably we think unless you do
it lets you transition carefully because
to where you know minimal shoe requires
more foot strength probably requires
more calf strength now you can develop
that strength but you're not going to
get it overnight right and so so most of
the time when you buy these shoes if you
buy a minimal shoe it actually comes
with with with warning saying you know
don't train your transition gradually
transition slowly build up carefully
don't don't do it all at once and I
think that's very good advice because
then because you can't suddenly just
change from one kind of body to the next
and I think if you do try to use minimal
shoes you know do so cautiously and
carefully and mindfully and something
hurts don't do it you know pain is it is
an ancient adaptation to tell you you're
doing something wrong
right when you ignore pain you're
ignoring your biology yes yeah take the
mystery done about that WH returning on
a minimalist running as
Q's with takes over so the question is
is there any evidence that barefoot
running is better phew well I would
argue that there never will be such a
study because I don't think barefoot
running is necessarily better for you I
think that what we can learn about
barefoot running is what I think is
important about running is how you run
and not what's on your feet and you can
run well in conventional shoes and you
can run poorly when you're barefoot the
advantage of being barefoot however and
by barefoot I mean actually barefoot not
a minimal shoe I hate the term barefoot
shoe it's an oxymoron it shouldn't be
allowed to be used but a minimal shoe
when you hit the ground and it and if
you hit the ground very hard it hurts
right so so one of the advantages of you
know incorporating a little bit of
barefoot running into your running is
that it teaches you not to slam into the
ground which is probably not a good idea
however simply taking off your shoes
doesn't make you a great runner
necessarily you know people rate who you
read Chris MacDougall's book Born to Run
which is yeah a lot of people read that
book and I thought oh my gosh I'm going
to throw in my shoes and I'm going to
become perfect right and like you know
everybody will love me right and and
I'll suddenly be able to run ultra
marathons and of course that's not true
you takes time and not everybody can do
it and not certainly not easily and you
can still run poorly barefoot so I think
we have a lot to learn about running
from barefoot running but I think what
matters about barefoot running just like
with with other aspects of evolution is
it teaches something about how our
bodies were evolved and so that we can
figure out intelligently how to make
decisions about how to use their body so
you don't have to be barefoot to get the
benefits of what we're learning from
barefoot running I think it's kind of
fun and I think people should I think
it's fun to try most people are afraid
to take their shoes off and go running I
think they're going to hurt themselves
and actually if you run barefoot on a
hard surface you sir your body often
switches to you know forefoot striking
and you learn to run in a gentle way but
this means you're going to run perfectly
and you can still enjoy yourself so you
have to be very careful and that's why
that's why I'm skeptical a lot of you
know the Paleo diet and these primal
movements is just just going back to an
old way of life doesn't necessarily
guarantee health after all
hunter-gatherers do not evolve to be
healthy they evolve to have to be
healthy only insofar as it help them
survive to have more offspring right
they didn't we didn't evolve to be happy
either or to be or you know we've ought
to be anxious and
be nervous and to be depressed sometimes
these are all adaptations
it's just that in our world today they
sometimes get out of control and I think
we can learn a lot from from biology
about our biology from studying things
like barefoot running or the effects of
physical activity but doesn't mean we
have to just simply analogize our life
back to two such simple you know to back
ancient ways of living yes
are there is scientific proof Oh
connection between all organic the kind
of uses day so the question is a
relation between organic food and
disease I'm not an expert on that so I'm
going to I study body as I'm not I'm not
I'm not an expert on that so I wouldn't
presume to answer one last question
it was Neil's Gutenberg he did a jelly
under any relation Europe but it hits a
Jewish procreate with Europe it was
ready and to Eve and in 1968 it's a
jewel of the Yemen right but my book
books being important but Yemen emigrate
able to look at that I have not looked
at those those purposes ago it's a great
study population to look at absolutely
good idea
all right well thank you so much